[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire de ce
grand JT le témoignage de l'archéologue
René Elter membre de l'ONG première
urgence internationale il était dans la
bande de gazale de l'attaque du Hamas
evoge télévision a recueilli son
témoignage à son retour vous allez voir
ils sont policiers et athlètes de haut
niveau ils défendront les couleurs de la
France aux Jeux Olympiques tv78 les a
accompagné lors d'un regroupement au
Centre national du football de
Clairefontaine et puis avec notre
partenaire via Occitanie nous vous
emmènerons découvrir le premier café à
chien ce lieu toulousain qui ne désemple
pas à pour ambition de permettre de
partager un moment câlin avec notre
meilleure amie et pourquoi pas de
l'adopter commençons ce journal avec le
souvenir celui du 11 novembre et du 13
novembre le 13 novembre 2015 Sébastien
était au Bataclan avec un ami venu du
sud spécialement pour assister au
concert des Eagle of death metel dans la
fusse l'homme a survécu au drame 8 ans
après les attentats il a tenu à se
recueillir auprès des familles des
victimes comme chaque année pour
Sébastien après le drame il est plus que
jamais important de célébrer la vie m
lanfor la rencontrer pour 20 minutes TV
écoutez je suis là pour rendre hommage à
ceux qui ont injustement perdu leur vie
ce jour-là et pour célébrer de l'autre
côté le fait d'être encore là pouvoir
aimer respirer profiter je viens je
viens chaque année à Paris pour faire
cette commémoration qui est qui est
vitale pour moi j'étais avec un ami que
j'ai heureusement pas perdu ce soir-là
et qui vient de d'être papa aujourd'hui
c'est extraord ordinaire comme la la
l'univers s'équilibre et aujourd'hui
voilà c'est une victoire de la vie une
double victoire de la vie aujourd'hui
j'ai appris ça en venant je crois que ça
a fait ma journée là de voir tout le
monde aujourd'hui c'est très important
parce que on prend un bain de vie on
prend un bain de de fraternité on prend
un bain d'empathie aussi ce sont proches
des gens qui ont perdu quelqu'un on se
sent proche des gens qui sont morts
aussi et on aimerait leur rendre hommage
de la de la manière la plus juste on
veut célébrer la vie aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça que après on va se retrouver
pour pour échanger ce qu'on a fait parce
que il y a des il y a des gens qu'on
voit qu'une fois dans l'année he donc
ici aujourd'hui aujourd'hui et c'est
pour ça qu'on est là aussi perpétuer le
souvenir de la Première Guerre mondiale
devient de plus en plus compliqué avec
le temps pour la 8e année les enfants de
plusieurs écoles du Pays d'Armance dans
l'Aube se sont retrouvés au pied du
monument au mort à l'occasion des
commémorations autour du 11 novembre
1918 afin d'entretenir et de diffuser le
souvenir de l'armistice et en
particulier de tous ceux qui se sont
battus pour la France en général c'est
un reportage de notre partenaire Canal
32 sur
place la cérémonie est devenue un moment
fort des commémoration autour du 11
novembre 1918 dans le département un
moment clé même car il touche un public
qui n'a pas l'habitude de rendre hommage
à ceux qui se sont battus le devoir de
mémoire est parfaitement réalisé par ses
enfants enfants avec le projet
pédagogique on arrive à leur inculquer
un petit peu cet effort de présence sur
les monument défilé lecture de lettres
de poilu dépts de GERB et champ dédiés à
la thématique 2023 à savoir les femmes
dans la grande guerre ont ponctué le
rendez-vous organisé cette année à Ha
puiseau nous l'appelons laad nousons la
nuit nous y pensons le jour une
cérémonie présidée pour la première fois
par la préf de l'aube une immense
émotion et je crois qu'elle été partagée
par tous les participants à cette
cérémonie qui est unique dans le
département par son ampleur ça j'en suis
certaine et à mon avis au-delà du
département aussi les enfants sont très
curieux ils posent beaucoup de questions
et je pense que ça les intéresse c'est à
nous adultes de de faire cet effort de
transmission dans l'Aube comme ailleurs
politique état et association essaye de
poursuivre au quotidien cette
sensibilisation aux faits historiques le
fait de s'adresser à un jeune public qui
plusit acteur de la cérémonie sur un
jour d'école est perçu comme un à tout
pour le futur le travail qui est fait
dans les écoles et dans l'eau
particulièrement est très très efficace
on le voit aujourd'hui avec des jeunes
de la plus petite école he de la
maternelle et tout le primaire mobilisé
sensibilisé vous savez ils se
souviendront qu'ils sont venus déposer
des fleurs ici au monument au Mor qu'ils
ont participé avec les élus avec leurs
instituteurs l'édition 2024 de la
cérémonie désormais traditionnelle sera
organisé à vos
NOM plus près de nous la guerre entre le
Hamas et Israël fait toujours rage René
Elter en est un rescapé il est
archéologue et membre de l'ONG première
urgence internationale début octobre il
était dans la bande de Gaza lors de
l'attaque du Hamas réfugié au sud du
territoire palestinien durant 3 semaines
il a enfin pu être évacué début novembre
il témoigne de son vécu et de ses
inquiétudes pour ceux qui l'a laissé en
Palestine aujourd'hui dévasté par la
guerre marie-del rogovitz et Hélène le
plat l'ont rencontré pour VOG télévision
regardez c'est un rescapé le vogien René
Elter archéologue et membre de l'ONG
première urgence internationale était
dans la bande de Gaza lors de l'attaque
du Hamas réfugié au sud du territoire
palestinien durant 3 semaines il est
évacué et de retour en France le 3
novembre mais le traumatisme est
toujours présent il y a eu cette attaque
insensé comme il dit sur son téléphone
les photos avant et après le 7 octobre
ça c'est le 4
octobre on a voulu se faire plaisir on
s'est acheté des glaces à 6h30 je suis
sorti de chez moi et au moment où
j'ouvre la porte des centaines et des
centaines de de roquettes sont tirées
partent dans le ciel de Gaza vers Israël
c'était très impressionnant j'avais
l'impression en fait qu'une une énorme
pieuvre en fait était en train de se
réveiller et qu'elle jitait C ces
tentacules tellement qu'il y avait de de
de roquette il peinene à trouver ses
mots pour ces 3 semaines passées à se
protéger des bombardements incessants
quand vous avez des des roquettes qui
partent dans un sens elles vont bien
tomber quelque part et puis ensuite vous
avez des bombes qui tombent pas loin de
vous
et vous pouvez constater par le bruit
parce que on a eu cette chance justement
de ne pas être exposé directement mais
par le bruit vous entendez des immeubles
qui s'écroulent il a laissé derrière lui
son équipe et surtout ces jeunes
palestinien d'une vingtaine d'années
qu'il formait au métier de l'archéologie
à la valorisation du patrimoine et son
téléphone qu'il ne quitte pas lui permet
de rares contact mais note pas son
inquiétude ça c'est une je journaliste
d'aljazira je sais j'ai essayé de lu
écrire je sais pas si si elle est encore
vivante la tragédie humaine prime mais
la guerre n'épargne pas non plus les
sites archéologiques dont il avait la
responsabilité en fait on était en train
de de de clore un très gros chantier
qu'on a commencé au début de cette année
donc c'est un cimetière de la période
romaine qui est daté entre le 1er siècle
avant Jésus-Christ et le 2e siècle après
Jésus-Christ un ensemble totalement
inédit pour pour la région par sécurité
et parce que ce n'est pas son rôle il se
refusera comme monter le conflit il
concédera juste que l'attaque du Hamas a
été un électrochoc au gouvernant du
monde dit-il d'éteindre le
feu c'est l'Organisation météorologique
mondiale qui a fait ce constat en
seulement 50 ans le nombre de
catastrophes climatiques a été multiplié
par 5 connaître les risques naturels et
technologiqu et ainsi adopter les bons
gestes face à eux devient donc
primordial c'est l'objectif de la
journée tous résilients face au risque
instauré par le gouvernement depuis 2022
et enc les élèves de l'école du poné à
lectia ont testé un jeu permettant de
découvrir les différents risques de
manière ludique le lieutenant Frédéric
orsony répond aux questions de Pierre
Pasco Len et de enorscini pour télépaisé
regardez alors à pontch ben on a bien
évidemment les risques naturels comme
les inondations on a bien vu dans les
années 2015-26 où ça a été quand même
assez important mais il y a aussi
d'autres risques comme le transport de
mièr dangereus on a le dépôt d'explosif
pas loin non plus on a vraiment mis ça
en relation avec la commune avec le lieu
dans lequel ils vivent et ils ont pu
voir des vidéos ou des
ou des photos de B de choses qui se sont
passées ici et du coup ils se sentent
vraiment concernés ils ont pu aussi
recueillir des des
informations dans les familles enfin on
en a beaucoup discuté dans notre
entourage le principe c'est de de faire
que les enfants et les adultes également
euh a une une culture du risque voilà
savoir comment se comporter en cas
d'aléa et savoir aussi puisque ça
rejoint beaucoup la la prévention euh
savoir aussi comment faire pour que bah
on ait de moins en moins de chance dans
le futur ben de d'aller vers ses risques
vers ses allias à Firmini dans la Loire
depuis 2020 deux professeurs et un
groupe d'élèves ont créé une web radio
afin de mieux comprendre ce qu'est un
média cette semaine ils ont eu la fierté
d'inaugurer leur tout premier studio
d'enregistrement et pour l'occasion ces
journalistes en herbe ont interviewé
leur directeur académique marieelis
Parot était présente ente pour TL7 dans
la
Loire la radio
de la radio qui rassemble tous les
élèves bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur la radio 427 la radio de
valdec voici la première interview des
élèves du collège valdec Rousseau dans
leur nouveau studio d'enregistrement
l'invité du jour Thierry dicly le
directeur académique de la Loire merci
pour vos questions alors les trois
journalistes en herbe sont en 4e et sont
fiers d'avoir préparé l'interview grâce
à cette table de mixage et des micro
flamban neuf financé à hauteur de 8600 €
par l'État et le département les élèves
vont pouvoir créer leurs propres
émissions et il commence à saisir les
bases du métier de journaliste faut pas
croire toutes les informations qu'on
nous donne faut vérifier il y a beaucoup
de fake news et faut pas croire à tout
ce qu'on nous dit c'est pour ça qu'il
faut regarder aussi sur les médias et
pas que sur les réseaux indispensable
pour les deux professeurs en charge de
ce projet l'éducation au médias et à
l'information est nécessaire dans la
société actuelle première chose qu'on
leur apprend c'est qu'est-ce qu'un média
parce que la plupart du temps pour eux
un média c'est un réseau social donc
c'est très important pour nous de leur
apprendre ce qui est un média et on leur
apprend également ce qu'est une
information parce que ça peut paraître
anodin mais c'est très important de
comprendre ce qui'est une information la
déontologie la vérification ou encore le
parcours de l'information voilà les
codes journalistiques que les
professeurs transmettent fiers de leurs
élèves ils ventent les mérites de
l'enseignement de projet et on s'est
rendu compte surtout du fait que le
média radiophonique permettait surtout
l'exigence de l'écriture parce que tout
passe par une préparation écrite et donc
on a une valorisation évidente des
compétences orales et écrites chez nos
jeunes le collège de Firmini n'est pas
le seul à être doté d'un studio
d'enregistrement h en tout dans la Loire
sont
installés parce que la transmission des
savoir-faire est essentielle les
Compagnons du Tour de France prennent
soin de leurs apprentis en offrant à ses
futurs menuisiers couvreurs ou bien
encore plombiers leur caisse à outil
c'est une cérémonie bon enfant qui s'est
déroulé tout près de Limoge au cœur du
centre de formation de ces artisans
d'exception
pour cette alimoge Tom Capron a
rencontré Vivian Boris formateur en
menuiserie et en
ébénisterie les outils en fin de compte
on les garde longtemps toute une vie et
c'était important voilà de pouvoir
donner les les outils de base en fait de
la caisse à outil auprès de ses
apprenants puisque voilà il y a ce
moment d'échange et ce moment voilà
peut-être de de passation ou de ou de
transmission j'en sait rien de de de
métier et de passion il y a vraiment un
travail d'équipe une cohésion de groupe
et et ça on le trouve ici à la féd en
centre de formation mais aussi dans les
entreprises en fait donc on on essaie de
former euh au monde du travail mais
aussi au monde en
général après la caisse à outils si vous
ne voulez pas sortir votre machine à
coudre voici le bonus réparation textile
lancé officiellement la semaine dernière
par le ministère de la transition
écologique pour lutter contre le
gaspillage doté d'un fond de 154
millions d'euros le dispositif permet au
consommateurs de obtenir un Rabet pour
faire réparer ses vêtements et ses
chaussures au lieu de les jeter à
condition que le cordonnier ou le
retoucheur soit labellisé et ils sont
très peu à Bordeaux et en Gironde comme
l'a constaté Dominique parmontier pour
TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest réparer plutôt qu'acheter du
neuf c'est le principe de ce nouveau
bonus qui vous offre entre 6 et 25 € de
remise si vous faites réparer vos
vêtements par exemple 7 € pour le
rapiessage d'une pièce trouée facturé
habituellement 12 €
ou encore 25 € de remise pour un
ressemelage de chaussures en cuir à
environ 90 € un dispositif diversement
apprécié par les Bordelet vous pensez
que vous allez vous en servir bah pas
vraiment j'achète déjà mes vêtements en
seconde main donc j'ai rien à remettre
quoi actuellement quand j'ai des accros
ben je fais moi-même mais je pas du
temps donc si j'ai un bonus pour le
faire ben pourquoi pas je suis
absolument pas d'accord avec ça parce
que quelque part ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que tout va être gratuit en
France et pourtant rien n'est gratuit
donc ça veut dire que qui va payez-vous
moi et autre ça peut inciter les gens à
acheter des vêtements de qualité parce
qu'ils sauront que ils peuvent les
garder pourquoi pas il y aura ceux qui
jouent le jeu et ceux qui monent les
prix quoi qu'il en soit pour en
bénéficier il faut vous rendre chez un
professionnel labélisé par les
cororganise refashion c'est le cas de
cette cordonnière de la rive droite de
Bordeau une des rares indépendantes à
avoir adhéré mais aujourd'hui elle
trouve que le dispositif n'est pas
intéressant pour des artisans comme elle
c'est à nous de faire toutes les
démarches pour que les clients
bénéficient de ces de ces baisses de ces
de ce bonus et le problème c'est qu'on
n' pas le temps enfin moià j'ai je l'ai
fait hier j'ai fait cas pour une
personne qui justement effectivement on
n'aurait pas fait réparer toutes ces
chaussures s'il n'y avait pas eu le
bonus sauf que ça m'a pris un temps fou
et que je pourrais pas le faire sur
toutes les paires de chaussures et on
doit même avancer l'argent finalement
puisqu'on baisse nos tarifs et on sera
remboursé plus tard donc là il y a un
petit souci euh les cordonniers on n'
pas les les les les reins assez solides
et puis c'est pas notre rôle d'avancer
les subventions Delta quoi enfin c'est
un peu bizarre à ce jour une petite
douzaine seulement de professionnels
sont labilisés en Gironde 600 en France
et en majorité des grandes enseignes de
vêtements pas sûr que cela aide à lutter
contre le gaspillage 700000 tonnes de
vêtements sont achetés chaque année en
France les deux tiers finissent dans les
décharges l'objectif du dispositif c'est
de réparer 21,6 millions de pièces d'ici
2018 contre 16 millions en
2019 tout à fait autre chose ouvrons
maintenant une large consacré au sport
né à Auckland en Nouvelle-Zélande le
deuxème ligne du Stade Toulousain
Emmanuel mafou a officiellement été
naturalisé français par la préfecture de
hautegaron il est désormais éligible
pour jouer pour le 15 de France et
s'entraîner à chanter la Marseillaise on
l'écoute au micro de notre partenaire de
la Dépêche du Midi pour ma famille aussi
il y a bientôt le petit en décembre donc
ça me touche beaucoup au fond du cœur de
d'être finalement en français et je suis
très fier VO cette première marseillaise
oui oui là j'ai
j'entraî à la maison un peu et quand
quand le bleu quand il joue j'ai
j'essayé de de chanter surensem mais
ouais ça fait du bien d'être c'est la
première fois français et ouà c'est bien
dans 261 jours ils défendront les
couleurs de la France aux Jeux
Olympiques pour préparer l'échéance les
athlètes de l'équipe de la police
nationale se sont réunis pour 3 jours de
séminaire au Centre national du football
de Clairefontaine un moment privilégié à
quelques mois des JO partagés par
Gabriel Gontier pour tv78 regardez 3
jours dédiés à l'optimisation de la
performance la soixantaine d'athlètes de
l'équipe police nationale a participé à
son dernier rassemblement au Centre
national de Clairefontaine un moment
privilégié à quelques mois des Jeux
Olympiques on a fait beaucoup
d'activités autour de la prépa mentale
que ce soit sur l'évaluation de la
personnalité ou sur des des points
d'ancrage pour moi c'était une
découverte déjà au niveau de de la
structure parce que c'est la première
fois que je venais ici on a pu découvrir
les sportifs qui ont intégré le
dispositif récemment aujourd'hui on est
65 sportifs donc c'était très
enrichissant on arrive à rencontrer des
champions médailles olympiqu on B on se
retrouve dans à Claire Fontaine dans le
centre de football enfin c'est des
opportunités que on Coss pas ça tous les
jours et ben c'est ben grâce à la police
l'objectif du séminaire le partage
d'expérience et la préparation physique
et mentale durant 3 jours les athlètes
ont pu s'essayer à différentes activités
collectives un séjour durant lequel les
sportifs ont également pu rencontrer
d'anciens médaillés également membrre de
la police avec David Douillet et
d'autres sportifs de haut niveau on est
venu pour donner nos
expériences autour des Jeux Olympiques
voilà comment aborder cette cet
événement planétaire potentiel il y a
surtout un bon engouement il y a des des
jeunes qui sont très ambitieux une
initiative permise par la police
nationale qui soutient depuis 1982 les
athlètes qui évoluent dans ces rang on a
fait un grand dîner hier soir on a les
directeurs de de la police nationale qui
sont venus à leur rencontre et c'était
important pour les athlètes de voir à
quel point en fait l'institution
s'investit pour leur soutien et ce n'est
pas sans émotion que la commissaire a
dit
[Applaudissements]
Kevin Lott est tétraapégique de
naissance c'est à l'adolescence qu'il a
découvert le tir sportif après un
passage à la fête foraine après une
première participation au JO de Tokyo il
espère décrocher le sésame qui lui
permettrait de représenter la France au
j de Paris en
2024 regardez ce reportage de Damien de
cran pour Lyon Capitale TV
lctv
[Applaudissements]
comme chaque jour Kevin lo est au pas de
tir à
l'entraînement athlète de haut niveau il
pratique le paratier sportif à la
carabine sur les distances 10 et 50 m
tétraplégique de naissance il se
passionne pour cette discipline dès son
plus jeune âge j'ai commencé le tir il y
a ça fera bientôt presque 20 ans j'ai
découvert en étant gamin comme
d'habitude à la fête foraine que je m'en
sortais pas mal on se mettait des petits
challenges avec avec la famille les
cousins et puis comme mon père était
dans l'armée il m'a inscrit après dans
son stand je voulais faire une activité
pour être un peu comme tout le monde il
y en a c'était le foot et la mobilette
les trucs et du coup j'ai trouvé ce
sport qui m'a permis aussi dans la vie
quotidienne de pouvoir me concentrer un
peu plus notamment pour les études
j'étais souvent tête en l'air et du coup
ça m'a amené
ouais du calme concentration et tout ça
Kevin edway obtient un premier titre
national en junior deux autres vont
suivre chez les seniors les bons
résultats s'enchaînent et c'est en 2020
que sa carrière d'école ce qui lui
permet de participer à sa première
olympiade à Tokyo l'année suivante en
Norvège il décroche le titre européen
puis devient champion du monde par
équipe à Lima au Pérou en septembre
dernier avec un record du monde à la clé
aujourd'hui il n'a qu'un ObjC en tête
réaliser les quotas pour décrocher son
ticket pour Paris 2024 bah déjà faire
les Jeux de Tokyo c'était pas à espérer
mais je les ai fait et là c'est sûr que
quand on en a déjà fait un on veut en
refaire un donc oui là c'est l'objectif
principal c'est d'y participer et
pourquoi pas voilà les faire mieux que
les fait à Tokyo la course au sésame est
donc lancée Kevin va s'en vololer pour
les Émirats arabes unis en décembre pour
une épreuve de la Coupe du monde mais
c'est à New da en mars prochain qu'il
devra saisir son ultime chance pour
décrocher sa qualification et
représenter la France aux Jeux
paralympiques de Paris
2024 ce n'est pas encore une discipline
olympique mais le bras de fer cette
activité millénaire pratiqué pour
comparer sa force a été reconnu
discipline sportive en
1977 un club dédié à cette discipline a
ouvert ses portes en nzer et son succès
ne se dém pas pour Télé grrenoble Mirko
preci S Esser à la
discipline pomme contre pomme face à
face c'est une guerre de force qui se
joue sur la table de bras de fer freedom
fitness est le premier club à proposer
ce sport en iser depuis son ouverture en
juillet le club accueille de nouveaux
adhérents toutes les semaines j'ai
rejoint le club il y a à peu près un
mois j'ai commencé cette discipline
parce que j'ai vu les autres pratiquer
et du coup ma curiosité a pris le dessus
et j'ai voulu en savoir plus c'est pour
pour aller chercher mes limites parce
que je sais que c'est pas uniquement la
force qui joue dans cette discipline
c'est également beaucoup de technique ça
fait 3 4 ans que je me suis intéressé au
bras de fer et puis là ça fait voilà ça
fait 6 mois qu'on commence à s'entraîner
pas trop mal mais bon on tatonne quoi
même en s'entraînant pas très bien
techniquement au début on a une bonne
progression cette épreuve de force est
une activité millénaire pratiquée pour
se comparer à un ami à un rival ou à un
membre de sa famille le bras de fer a
été reconnu comme discipline sportive en
1977 c'est aujourd'hui un sport codifié
avec ses règles et ses techniques c'est
pas le bras de qu'on peut faire dans les
bares ou autres il y a des règles il y a
un travail spécifique à faire pour
pouvoir progresser dedans on peut croire
que celui qui est le plus fort plus
costaud va être forcément le meilleur
sur table or ça rien à voir au bras de
fer la clé c'est le poignet les
adhérents travaillent spécifiquement les
muscles pronateurs et fléchisseurs des
avant-bras dans le bras de fer en fait
il y a deux axes à travailler ce qu'on
appelle le rise et le CUP le poignet est
super important au vo fa c'est avec le
poignet qu'on peut désactiver la force
de l'autre chacun applique sa technique
et puis s'adapte en fait la technique
qui subit donc c'est très rapide un
match ne dure que 5 secondes les plus
serrés peuvent s'allonger jusqu'à 40
secondes dans de nombreux pays de l'Est
le bras de fer est le sport national en
France la discipline ne compte que 17
clubs pour 350 licenciés partons
maintenant à la découverte d'un concept
original on connaissait les café à chat
place désormais au premier café à chien
à Toulouse le lieu unique en Occitanie a
pour ambition de permettre de partager
un moment câlin avec notre meilleur ami
et pourquoi pas de l'adopter pourvia
ocitan Hervé Lisa a eu du mal à résister
à la
tentation caliner un chien tout en
buvant un thé ou en mangeant une tarte
c'est ce que propose ce salon dans le
centreeville
Toulousain je pense qu'il sent l'odeur
de mon chien sur mes vêtements mais des
chiens appartenant au gérant mais aussi
en recherche de foyers comme melon cet
aréjoie de 6 mois le canité veut
sensibiliser sur une adoption réfléchie
et responsable qui a été récupéré par
l'association musotopia donc c'est une
association de protection animale qui
récupère des chiens abandonnés et ou
maltraités et qui les place dans des
familles d'accueil et nous en fait on
collabore avec C cette association
toulousaine et l'idée c'est que on mette
en lumière ces chiens qui sont à la
recherche d'une famille et quand venant
au canité et bien le processus
d'adoption ou de trouver une famille
d'accueil soit beaucoup plus rapide pas
question de chouchouter ces animaux
n'importe comment sur chaque table une
charte sur le comportement à adopter on
parle un petit peu à la place du chien
pour que ça soit mieux perçu comme par
exemple laisse-moi venir à toi ne
m'appelle pas plusieurs fois par mon
prénom j'ai la tête qui tourne pour que
les gens en fait se rendent compte que
ben ce sont des animaux des êtres
vivants et qu'il a une façon de
s'adresser à eux et que ce ne sont pas
des peluches un concept dans le respect
de l'animal qui séduit la clientèle ça
m'a tout de suite plu de savoir qu'il y
avait des chiens qu'on pouvait passer du
temps avec eux dans un café pouvoir
travailler c'est toujours agréable de
venir manger dans un salonté et en plus
avec les chiens ça rajoute un petit plus
moi j'adore et pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient amener leurs chiens des
ateliers spécifiques sont programmés
deux fois par mois environ on organisera
un événement canin il peut y avoir des
ostéopathes animaliers par exemple ou
une éducatrice comportementaliste qui
viendront feront une petite conférence
mettront en place quelques ateliers des
événements autour du bien-être animal
donc le café est ouvert tous les jours
du mardi au
samedi et puis le prix de Flore 2023 a
été attribué à Maria Pourchet qui a été
récompensée pour son roman western avec
ce 7e roman La vogène native d'Épinal
signe un des textes marquants de la
rentrée western raconte la rencontre
d'Alexis et de Chloé un acteur à succès
et une femme qui a décidé de vivre seul
avec son fils retranché du monde et à la
campagne Chloé becbéd a recueil sa
première
réaction qutin bra Ango dans ces noms là
tout est tout est littéraire tout est
rock tout est pointu c'est exactement le
club auquel on a envie d'être identifié
je suis très très F de rejoindre club
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition du Grand JT des territoires au
revoir à
[Musique]
tous